Did you see? Uh,
I can't even tell you how much I thought about
kid rock tweeting to a Taylor Swift.
I just can't tell you how much I've thought about it. It's so weird.
It's weird. How much a political, like a political stance can divide your fans.
Like somebody I was talking about guns and, and somebody was like, I mean,
every time I tweet and it's not that to me, that's not even a political thing.
Like if just people are dying,
you got to fix the situation and people like stale set of politics, comedian.
And I'm just like, I CA I don't know how to, um, I don't know how to do it.
You know, I just, whatever I read responded to some guy who was like, I'm the,
if you think being political mean talking about people dying as being political,
then I'm the vice-president because you got them right on political. And,
uh, so I, I, but,
but the T the kid rock thing is just such a mess.
It's weird. This is like a guy like me who doesn't know about kid rock.
Like would, if, if I didn't know anything about him,
like, I don't care. Like,
I don't care if you think that all Americans need guns.
I D I don't think that, uh,
that there should be automatic weapons for sale to civilian.
Also. Here's the other thing, too, when people are like, yeah, well,
the government, you know,
this rule was put in place where the government cannot be. Dude,
the government can Nuchia
you think you're going to hold off the government with an assault rifle.
They got nukes. Do you know what that, what also?
They have more people
did. Oh, Oh yeah, dude. Hey, keep your,
yeah. Keep the government away of your, uh,
from your townhouse with an AK 47 and 32
bullets. But you know what?
The government has more people, dude.
They'll crash at tank through your townhouse.
[inaudible]
Like, what are you talking about? Yeah. Well,
I'm here for when the government tries to take over, it already took over.
They've got so many people. So that's a weirdest.
Um, argument for me, that being said.
I, you know, security, have a guy with a gun in the Walmart,
protecting everyone to have that. I don't, you know, whatever.
It's like that guy who 'em the other day, who who's,
who held the.
Other guy at Bay.
Because he was security and he had a gun and he was holding the gun.
Uh, and w w w who brought in an assault? Right? A rifle.
I don't know where it was. You remember something like seven, 11?
I went with a nose.
He held them. Good, good, good, good dude. Have armed guards around.
I don't give a, but like I saw that picture of a guy who had a,
the assault rifle. And he was like in line at a coffee bean, like, dude,
leave it in the car.
Somebody was like, would you be.
More scared or less scared.
If you saw this guy in the, in the coffee bean.
Cause you know that he could protect.
Hey, got the guy at Jane's on, you know,
if you were in jeans, don't have an assault rifle,
dude wear cammo and be in the government or army.
It's so weird.
Tivy like inline with an assault rifle over your back.
And you're just like, yeah,
let me get a anything.
Oh, you got shy. Yeah.
Don't come to me for political views too.
You're straight up. Like, well dude lost a podcast fan.
I write at K you know,
side of the Nara dude.
I told you silly goose time period. Um,
but yeah, it's hilarious.
They're getting rid of video games and that movie, the hunt,
they canceled that crazy.
They canceled that. Universal canceled the movie, the hunt.
It was going to be out, put it up, bring it up in here. Uh,
it was going to be out and uh, they just gone.
Just gone because of how I guess universal
cancels the hunt release, universal pictures, scroll up.
Universal speakers canceled the release of his upcoming thriller. The hunt.
The film was presented previously set to hit theaters September 27th when
universal pictures had already paused the marketing campaign for the hunt.
After thoughtful consideration,
I get that the studio has decided to cancel our plans to release the film
I spokesperson for universal set it in a statement.
We stand by our filmmakers and we'll continue to distribute films in partnership
with the bold and visionary creators. Like those,
now's not the time to release this film. They're not going to release it.
That's the thing, dude, you know, on one hand, it's like sensor, you know,
I get, I get being like sensitive and, but also that censorship,
it really is because Trump was saying, you know,
I loved the tweet too. That Trump did. It was just a mess
about it. He was just like, what did he say?
Let look it up here. I'm. I'm. I'm. I can't get the code in. I'm. All good.
I can't get my code in. Uh, what did he say?
Oh yeah. He told me he, but he didn't say the tonight in it, dude.
He tweet so much. Dude.
Liberal Hollywood is racist at the highest level. Okay.
And with great anger and hate, they'd like to call themselves elite,
but they are not elite.
Now this is weird because like I'm in Hollywood and I've never heard
someone in Hollywood be like, you know, I'm elite.
They do. Yeah. They, yeah, exactly. They say that,
you know,
people are only saying the Hollywood elite when they're making fun of Hollywood,
like nobody thinks they're elite. Like who thinks they're elite?
Unless you're like a soldier that went through training.
You're not elite because you were in a what's that movie with
Milo Ventimiglia and the dog. You're not elite.
Cause you're Jenna Elfman. You know, you're just in a, in some
elite, but he's right. They like to call themselves elite,
but they are not elite.
In fact it is imagined me thinking I'm elite because I was in the show, Whitney.
Well, you know, I'm a leak.
Cause I was in an episode of workaholics and Undateable.
In fact that is often the people that they strongly oppose that are actually the
elite. Okay.
So now he's calling himself elite.
The movie coming out is made in order to inflame and cause chaos,
they create their own violence and then try to blame others.
They are the true racist and very bad for our country. I like how basic he gets.
Sometimes they're very bad for our country. Like it's like,
like he's learning about it. And like he just figured it out there.
The true racist. I don't understand. He tweets a mess.
I don't understand how he's saying.
It's that, that makes them the true racists.
It doesn't have anything to do with race. Okay.
Speaking of which, did you see what Biden said about the
that whatever?
Yeah. What a mess that.
Dude, he, I don't think that he, I don't know if he'll hold it together, man.
Could he look more like a pilot that like doesn't fly anymore?
Poor kids are just as bright as white kids. Ah,
major mistake.
I.
Mean just major mistake.
Imagine being up there saying that and then knowing you.
Up, he, he tried make it better too, which was the best afterwards.
He goes like this poor kids are just as smart and talented as white kids.
And then he goes and black kids and Asian, whatever.
No, I tooted runs away.
And the massages girls' shoulders real quick. I don't know, but I didn't do it.
I don't know. I mean, I don't,
I don't know enough about anybody's policies because I'm a ignoramus,
but that was like, Oh,
I mean, dude, that's so crazy.
How that's the kind of thing that can ruin you, you know,
after that you think has done, he he's just, he's just up too much.
Um, he just up too much. I don't know if he'd be good or bad, but I,
I did like how he went bingo though.
That's my favorite thing that any politician has ever done
because every politician is like, well, you know, we don't want to do this,
but we do want to do that. And so it's not a yes or no question,
but they were like, so you want to take a take away assault, rifles, bingo.
Like the like had a hard Dick when he said it.
I love that. That's hilarious to me. I just love,
I kind of don't even care what you believe in.
I love the way you believe in it is the best. Like,
but yeah, kid rock dude. When kid rock said the thing, uh, about,
about, uh, about, um, uh, Taylor Swift,
that's a mess too.
Taylor Swift wants to be a Democrat because she wants to be in movies period.
And it looks like she will suck the doorknob of Hollyweird to get their oldest
move in the book. Good luck girl, kid rock. Hey kid rock.
You don't have to sign your tweet. No. Why? Okay.
It says twice above the tweet, your name.
This is kid rock at kid rock Taylor Swift wants. We don't get to blah, blah,
blah. Good luck. Rock kid. Rock Republicans.
Love to sign the out of their tweet.
Like it's a letter like they did some sincerely kid rock.
Also kid rock is your name. You know,
don't sign off on anything. Cause your name is kid rock.
Um, so funny dude
also suck the doorknob off Hollyweird.
Dude. Hollyweird sucks. When people say that, are you a.
15 Year old chick on vacation.
Hollywood aired?
What a weird, you know.
Hollyweird suck the doorknob.
Like just say.
Imagine thinking.
Man,
like what did I tweeted about it? I think, and I wrote it. What did I say?
Just imagine being like, dude, I can't get over the fact.
Go down right there. No doubt down. Where is it?
tweet the other day.
I can't think about how weird Chiraq suite was of all the things that we met on
the road. You're mad that tells us what the Democrat,
but then I realized this it's it's better than that.
He thinks she's trying to get into movies by pretending she's a
Democrat dude. Like imagine her thought process. She's like, God,
I really want to do movies. I bet I could get cats if I went yeah, blue.
She's the biggest singer in the world.
Also somebody tweeted after that, they were like, Hey kid rock. Are you jealous?
Taylor Swift is in cats. That's so funny to think about kid rock being like,
Oh, like to watching the cats trailer and then having them be like,
Oh, off I made this movie without me, like,
and then saw Taylor Swift in it and then just is up in arms. Like.
What the they call me kid rock.
W why.
Are you mad? I guess.
That's the thing. When, when somebody says who's got a huge fan base is like,
okay, well them. Yes. Um,
know, now I got to speak out. Like you can just lose a lot of fans, I guess.
That's my favorite when people are just like, well.
Okay, I buy, I bought your last album. It's the last album years I buy,
like Taylor Swift could give a, you know,